oh hey how's the gun welcome to video
welcome to the impossible quiz part 2
the brothers were crazy about me making
another one cuz apparently I was halfway
done with this [ __ ] so we're gonna try
to finish it today I have no guarantees
this game is hilarious but god this game
pissed me off man
alright let me just go back to where we
were all right here we are the last time
I clicker because Marmite is known for
being disgusting so you think it's gonna
be YUM right then there's the people
who's like what is that
but no it's but pawed my night so
[ __ ] genius Shanghai is indeed the
largest city in China never been why is
there a Christian oh come on god this
could be any of these - oh god oh god
what is the digestive system it's
something investing jeez I'm not good
under pressure okay [ __ ] me I'm gonna
have to do all this [ __ ] again oh okay a
games console for a whole meat biscuits
a series of Oregon designed to break
down food what what no I hope you
remembered remember what
what am I supposed to remember I think
it should be this one but it really
[ __ ] isn't oh it's the order they
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
look Count Dracula one on the subject of
Dracula what is his favorite food oh
it's not blood and it's not urine it's
gotta be shepherd's pie
holy [ __ ] come on my chair breaking Oh
God it snapped it scared my tits off be
honest did you manage to do the last
question on your first go no I didn't
I'm [ __ ] lost on this one
skip it's simple click the math Oh will
do lead off king kelana cough cough
alone and bing get burner
ooblar doula doffed
haha I am the smartest [ __ ]
you even know it wetting down to use a
Swedish [ __ ] [ __ ] what a chicken
back Nuggets made up I actually want to
know this 100% tasteless white filth I
don't want to die which is true
PlayStation Portable is better than yes
ts is better than PlayStation Portable
egg is bigger than 28 I don't know if
there's something like wavelength going
on with me whoever made this [ __ ] click
the largest
can't click there what okay I guess it
worked what what do I do
how is the question Oh God puffing up a
hairball apparently why no now god damn
it okay and then the Lord
what hung up its in Australia oh my
[ __ ] god nugget
what happened did a kitty cat that was a
kitty cat oh god what do I know
d oh my god out naw [ __ ] that's the
[ __ ] ugly ass a big hairy arsonist
how did I make it to the [ __ ] cat
without even clicking oh my god are you
enjoying this quiz I guess yes my dog's
got no nose how does it using its name
oh Christ
search all this can't be too bad right
holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
ah ah how many questions does this quiz
I'm no one knows that for what for the
wad [ __ ] I guess I should pick the
one that looks like that one right yeah
sugar honey honey dead dead dead dead
dead
what is this mr. T's oven glove so what
is this question nice Marquis little
[ __ ] I'm escaped the answer is a
horseshoe you [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh the answer horses wear shoes what do
you mean what I made it I need a [ __ ]
break
I'm back let's finish this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that one what is this am I supposed to
stroke it Oh God come on that's
disgusting
what does DNA stand for do not
abbreviate national dyslexic organ SS
you only touch the shooting star are you
[ __ ] ah
commending jävla
what but I [ __ ] click skip did you
enjoy the last I hate this question many
o foolish have fun today escape did you
enjoy the space is a disgrace
I'm gonna skip I click was submitting
from this question that thing holy
[ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh should you get sanic which magical
property do dogs in what what is of cash
it's the only one that isn't really a
magical property [ __ ] me in there did
you enjoy the last question spaces I
love that blindness Oh God
Oh how many times is Michael Jackson
none wow they're impossible quiz player
allow me to give you a bit of I goddamn
it
it is top writer corner County night
what what do I do
well well well tear that match what
descending was this scary another one
what the [ __ ] where oh god it's probably
gonna be oh but how do I stop it if it
says deck Tony skip what what what do
you get if you put a number into your
calculation and then add a number to oh
my [ __ ] god
how many times did do you how do you add
a day plus 10 can you still remember no
it's a oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] we're blue red
blue
[Music]
no blue-red god I mean you do me a vet
may are you here
jab la beat Danny panin don't panic
don't panic don't [ __ ] panic Dean
idiot you're hotter hotter fun out the
yellow jab okay okay okay blue red blue
yellow suck my [ __ ] what do I do next
question
it's oh how many hearts how many holes
into polos
[Applause]
[Music]
what what what I don't want to see wha
wha oh my god under to touch the dots
before they disappear but how do it
again stop with the [ __ ] dots sorry
wha sorry
skip Thanks do the opposite don't click
the small yellow happy son I can't even
see my [ __ ] dick I can't say my dad
oh oh I found it holy [ __ ] [ __ ] do
the opposite after this I can see my do
the opposite how [ __ ] hard can it
[ __ ] me okay here we go keep it what
I'm on the road under on the road again
my only friend I won't take a break I'm
so [ __ ] ready to finish this like I'm
born to [ __ ] do this
out of all Rach things I ever played
this one just win surprise I know all
these answers by the back of my [ __ ]
it's that Sonic steak nice came all over
his pants what has been seen cannot be
unseen this is like Pro Elite gaming
right [ __ ] here
okay just pay attention to your do not
like that not back there at all my dad
is hammering oh oh whoa whoa whoa wow
how do you how do I do
Mozza but how did what what what what oh
god the numbers the numbers from last
good Google that [ __ ] Oh skip
what oh nice skip how to make your [ __ ]
okay so this is the last question is
potential of the easiest question there
is or your worst nightmare depending on
how you play good luck
use your skips I'm not I'm not even mad
anymore I don't even [ __ ] care
anymore no one knows when did all me
feet done just a funny dude oh no oh how
do you do you do well it was the thing
oh god oh god okay I wrote them down
nine shot the [ __ ] I wrote it I wrote it
I swear to God I wrote it why did I
click correct eight fifteen sixteen
oh god this dress oh god this dress oh
god this rest
oh [ __ ] mass out [ __ ] ray already god
oh god I wasn't ready for this
Oh No Oh No [ __ ] you [ __ ] you I forgot
about that one
okay [ __ ] [ __ ] okay I never take an
ass so hard my life
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
hi that was impossible quiz I'm gonna go
out and inject some bath salts in my ass
and then I'm gonna light myself on fire
outside if I don't one when I hang out
just leave a like and I'll appreciate it
hit subscribe read today I see you know
whether the next man is the perfect I'm
actually alright now we're talking man -
ha ha ha
[Music]